grazie benvenuti a tutti io sono marco
tinti sono un ingegnere civile e mi
occupo di costruzioni di edilizia il
titolo del talk e edilizia rigenerativa
gli elementi della natura a beneficio
dell'uomo e dell'ambiente
bene allora io principalmente costruisco
ristrutturo case con materiali naturali
e mi piace fare vedere il pianeta terra
perché quando noi usciamo di casa ci si
aprono gli spazi che apparentemente sono
illimitati vastissimi però se guardiamo
dallo spazio
ci rendiamo conto che noi siamo
innanzitutto miliardi miliardi di
persone mentre invece la terra dei
limiti a delle risorse limitate e noi in
edilizia quindi prendiamo risorse dalla
natura le trasformiamo purtroppo con dei
processi molto energivori che consumano
energia e dopo di che facciamo delle
costruzioni che poi richiedono
tantissima energia per essere riscaldate
raffresca te e oltretutto trasforma in
maniera permanente il territorio quindi
io nel mio sviluppo professionale mi
sono chiesto come poter migliorare
questo impatto
abbiamo trascorso da poco il periodo di
lock down in cui le nostre attività si
sono fermate però abbiamo visto stato
stufo effetto stupefacente per me vedere
come la natura gli animali si sono
riappropriati ripresi i propri spazi
l'aria è tornata pulita le acque sono
tornate limpide e quindi c'è stato
proprio un processo di rigenerazione
naturale che anche la chiave di lettura
del mio film è tonica e in gergo tecnico
tra di noi
si dice che ormai siamo diventati la
generazione indoor per che trascorriamo
più del 90 per cento del tempo in
ambienti chiusi dove lavoriamo ci
divertiamo giochiamo studiamo però ecco
visto che negli ultimi tempi la salute è
la parola chiave
ci chiediamo ma la vivere degli ambienti
indoor e sano ci fa bene il dottor
maurizio grandi che un oncologo e
professore dell'università di strasburgo
ha contato 400mila sostanze chimiche
utilizzate in edilizia
da un lato questo ha dato uno sviluppo
una velocità al settore però da un lato
ha un impatto pesante sulla struttura
sulla struttura e sulle persone
io qui ho voluto vedere vicini due
situazioni
una è un ospedale durante la pandemia
dovuto al co lead è un'altra un cantiere
edilizio dove si costruisce una casa ad
elevata efficienza energetica
vediamo gli operatori in un caso i
medici nell'altro caso gli operai che
adoperano tute e mascherine filtri
perché non possono contaminarsi da
quello che è contenuto nell'ambiente e
se pensate che poi nella casa di una
volta finita si chiuderà tutto e
qualcuno dovrà viverci
dobbiamo capire che utilizzare prodotti
chimici si si fa ma richiede molta
consapevolezza e molta attenzione nel
farlo durante il lock down
noi siamo stati anche io sono stato
molto tempo in casa
io già ad opera dei materiali che sono
naturali e che non vanno a impattare
sulla salute e sull'ambiente però stando
a casa mi sono chiesto ma com'è
possibile fare qualcosa di più perché
qui c'è un altro bisogno che è
inespresso perché chi è che di voi in
questo periodo non ha voluto desiderato
stare all'aria aperta stare in ambienti
naturali
ci risponde infatti rita trombin che una
psicologa ambientale che ormai la nostra
generazione vive una vera e propria
cronica carenza di rapporto con la
natura
ne soffrono soprattutto i bambini che
manifestano delle patologie tipo stress
e iper eccitazione e anche tipo del
sovrappeso e dice che bisogna che ci
prendiamo cura particolarmente di
bambini perché sono soggetti molto
delicati sono solo un quarto della
popolazione però sono il 100 per cento
del nostro futuro
quindi prenderci cura vuol dire
allenarli e portarli ad avere un
percorso educativo che li fa stare a
contatto con la natura
quindi ho trovato questo qualcosa di più
mi sono andato ad informare e ho trovato
dell'esperienza di vari ricercatori ad
esempio il dottor giuseppe barbiero
affiancato gli ha degli architetti degli
ingegneri nella riqualificazione
energetica di una scuola in val d'aosta
lui voleva che questa scuola oltre al
risparmio energetico avesse una capacità
di rigenerazione degli studenti e quindi
ha dato delle direttive precise che cosa
è riuscito a ottenere ha ottenuto che
gli alunni sottoposti allo stress
dell'apprendimento recuperavano in un
tempo che era del 20 40 per cento
ridotto alla fine dell'anno e come se
gli alunni avessero frequentato la
scuola per 35 giorni in più quindi la
generazione si è vista in una capacità
di recupero molto più veloce rispetto
agli stress quindi l'edilizia
rigenerativa si fonda sull'ipotesi
ipotesi della biophilia
biophilia vuol dire amore per la natura
per le forme di vita e non è una cosa
recente si parla dei primi anni 80 da
studi così come
wilson keller e loro sono partiti da
questo assunto
ma siccome l'uomo ha mosso i primi passi
iniziati evolversi nella savana quindi
vedeva sempre degli spazi naturali
materiali naturali caratteristici con le
loro forme loro dori delle forme
tondeggianti
ed è lì che l'uomo si è evoluto e ha
sviluppato il proprio sistema nervoso
l'ha sviluppata maniera tale da trovare
proprio la soddisfazione per le proprie
esigenze primarie ma anche per il
proprio benessere e quindi
istintivamente l'uomo cerca oggi di ri
per replicare di riportare fuori quelle
strategie per risolvere i problemi
quotidiani
quindi la loro ipotesi è che se noi
ricrea assimo quel contatto con la
natura
anche negli ambienti chiusi il livello
di benessere crescerebbe molto in
maniera molto elevata e quindi in questo
modo loro fanno l'ipotesi di portare la
biophilia nell'architettura quindi
creare proprio l'edilizia rigenerativa
in effetti se noi guardiamo siamo
partiti dall'abitare tipo in grotte e
caverne che aveva una forma tondeggiante
siamo passati anche attraverso la
costruzione di case a capanna per
resistere alla gravità e utilizzando i
materiali naturali del posto
poi ci siamo voluti con siamo arrivati
al boom edilizio in cui siamo andati ad
abitare
questa è una foto di milano quindi in
grosse città o periferie dove invece il
nostro cervello è continuamente
stressato da stimoli come l'inquinamento
atmosferico l'inquinamento acustico le
forme stesse degli edifici che sono
delle delle rette verticali orizzontali
che non hanno più nulla a che vedere con
l'ambiente naturale e quindi qui il
cervello non riesce mai a riposare da
abbassare il livello di attenzione
viceversa invece negli edifici
rigenerativi dove si sviluppa la
biophilia si servono delle cose molto
interessanti
allora il livello di benessere si è
visto aumentare di circa il 15 per cento
e la produttività aumenta del 6 per
cento e le prestazioni cognitive
aumentano del 10 12 per cento e
l'innovazione alla creatività aumenta di
circa il 10 per cento
quindi questi valori gli studiosi li
hanno osservati soprattutto in edifici
tipo in ambiti di lavoro di scuole ma
l'hanno visto ad esempio anche negli
ospedali
questo un ospedale a shanghai gli
studiosi hanno osservato che i degenti
hanno un periodo di ricovero molto più
corto recuperano molto prima lo stress e
quindi ecco degli enormi vantaggi negli
spazi di lavoro tutto questo crea anche
una forte legame anche affettivo tra al
posto di lavoro e l'azienda stessa per
cui lavoratore più difficilmente lascia
l'azienda
e si osserva anche invece che negli
spazi lavorativi da una cella biophilia
cosa succede che aumenta del 10 per
cento il tasso di assenteismo e mentre
invece il 75 per cento dei lavoratori
riferisce dei malesseri negli ambienti
chiusi
ecco elementi del bif il design
i ricercatori hanno teorizzato quali
caratteristiche dovrebbe dovrebbe avere
l'architettura per favorire il contatto
è una luce naturale principalmente
naturali un movimento dell'aria
allora voi pensate alla mattina quando
aprite la finestra sentite l'area
naturale che vi arriva addosso che come
una carica di energia del caffè e poi
anche un'elevata qualità e purezza
dell'aria interna quindi utilizzare dei
materiali sani che non inquinano
l'ambiente utilizzare possibilmente i
materiali vicini al contesto naturale in
cui sorge l'edificio dei materiali anche
che cambiano il proprio aspetto visivo
nel tempo come succede agli elementi
naturali e poi ecco avere degli edifici
degli spazi interni con delle visioni
molto ampie
i prospetti che profonde e poi avere
degli elementi architettonici che
stimolano la curiosità e poi ricercatori
invitano molto a curare la bellezza
architettonica degli edifici e qui noi
possiamo pensare a cos'è l'italia al
patrimonio storico italiano che per
moltissimi secoli e prodotto edifici di
un enorme bellezza e noi andiamo proprio
lì magari a passare le nostre attività
le nostre vacanze preferite
qui purtroppo la tecnologia non ci aiuta
ecco ad esempio volevo citare ascoli
piceno e detta la città del travertino
ed è anche proprio la sede dove stiamo
parlando quindi una città che ha
un'energia particolare grazie propria
questa pietra locale
quindi è stata utilizzata molto per
questa piazza del popolo per lastricare
la piazza quindi ad ascoli piceno
vediamo degli edifici massivi e
imponenti e il loro aspetto ricorda
molto le pareti di roccia delle montagne
circostanti
oppure vediamo i portici con la loro
forma ad arco che ricorda un po le
grotte dove lo trovava riparo nei primi
tempi e oggi travertino può essere
utilizzato come materiale per design
moderno oppure per ristrutturare negli
edifici storici
ecco un esempio notevole di edifici in
biophilia che ho trovato health e cura
varie che è la sede per le attività
culturali di un gruppo di tribù maori in
nuova zelanda
quindi loro hanno voluto ricreare questo
edificio riprendendo le forme naturali
come ad esempio quella dell'arco e qui
vedete un teatro che praticamente una
piazza di erba dove loro possono stare
comodamente e hanno utilizzato dei
materiali locali ma hanno voluto creare
un forte legame tra l'edificio e chi
l'ha costruito hanno utilizzato
dell'argilla locale che gli abitanti
stessi hanno modellato a mano creando di
mattoni e su questi mattoni hanno inciso
il loro nome
ho nominato l'argilla argilla materiale
naturale diffusissimo sono particelle
finissime che vengono dalla disgrazia
disgregazione delle altre rocce e
contengono molto
minerali disciolti dentro e molti medici
naturopati la conoscono proprio come
rimedio naturale ad esempio per
sfiammare le articolazioni per far
cicatrizzare le ferite per chiamare
l'intestino e quindi un vero e proprio
energizzante
l'uomo l'ha usato per secoli e millenni
la impastato con acqua e fibre vegetali
l'ha plasmato ad esempio come vedete
questo in questo gruppo di uomini in
quella plasmano per costruire dei muri e
io a cui ad esempio ho fatto durante
laboratorio fatto provare dei bambini un
intonaco di argilla costruzione bambini
se mi diceva si divertivano tantissimo
perché plasmandola ha detto si
liberavano dallo stress che avevano in
cumulato a scuola i giorni prima
e in tutto questo non ci sono alcun tipo
di reazione allergica né alcun tipo di
disagio fisico nel restare a contatto
con questo materiale
esiste già da secoli se non millenni una
vera e propria cultura storica
costruttiva di case in terra cruda in
ampie zone del mondo come vedete dalla
mappa sia in zone fredde che in zone
calde chi abita in queste case dice che
sono un ottimo riparo in tutte le
stagioni dell'anno
e qui siamo in medio oriente vediamo una
città fatta praticamente letteralmente
di condomini fatti di argilla e paglia
intrecciata e qui possiamo vedere un
paesaggio tornare nelle marche vedere un
paesaggio uno strano dove l'argilla
plasma plasma il territorio e dove in
pratica e da supporto per la produzione
del cibo del vino per esempio è qui
vediamo che ad esempio 300 anni fa i
contadini costruivano proprio con la
terra del campo tirano su le case e
quindi c'è proprio un continuo fra il
terreno naturale e la casa stessa
ma oggi la terra cruda sta entrando
prepotentemente un'architettura come
materiale
tecnologico e sostenibile vedete ad
esempio può essere lavorato per
mantenere la propria tessitura di
materiale naturale in cui si vede
proprio la tecnica costruttiva
oppure può essere utilizzato con dei
materiali più tecnologici veloci da
utilizzare
qui vediamo una casa che ha una
struttura di legno con dei pannelli
canapa isolanti ed è stata utilizzata
tanta terra cruda che la rende calda
d'inverno fresca d'estate senza
utilizzare energia ma la rende
soprattutto sana non contiene materiali
atossici contiene materia tossicia ecco
per la salute dell'uomo
l'impatto sull'ambiente della terra
cruda e veramente minimo è un materiale
particolare per l'economia circolare
vediamo in queste figure come ad esempio
viene presa dal terreno impastata
meccanicamente con acqua e fibra e poi
ecco si costruisce un edificio che verrà
utilizzato mantenuto nel tempo con un
dispendio energetico bassissimo e poi
l'edificio farà il suo corso
a fine vita la terra cruda potrà essere
riutilizzata per fare un altro edificio
oppure potrà tornare nell'ambiente in
tutto questo che il processo sia affatto
meccanicamente ho fatto a mano come
facevano gli antichi non c'è mai
l'utilizzo di energia fossile per la
trasformazione quindi rilascio di
sostanze climalteranti e praticamente
trascurabile
quindi ecco mi avvicino alla conclusione
e pochi giorni fa ursula von der leyen
ha fatto il discorso sullo stato
dell'unione europea e ci ha dato un
target ambizioso che è quello di ridurre
del 55 per cento entro
2030 le emissioni delle sostanze clima
alteranti in tutto questo l'edilizia
pesa per il 40 per cento che è tanto
quindi già oggi noi possiamo costruire
edifici costruirli strutturarli usando
dei materiali di derivazione vegetale
che hanno anche la capacità quindi di
assorbire di drenare l'anidride
carbonica dall'atmosfera poi possiamo
accoppiare questi materiali con la terra
cruda quindi otteniamo degli uffici
molto performanti come prestazioni
energetiche ma l'impatto sulla salute
dell'uomo praticamente nullo quindi ecco
molto ecologici e poi se noi riusciamo
anche a portare nell'architettura
l'edilizia i caratteri della biophilia
quindi l'edilizia rigenerativa otteniamo
anche degli edifici proprio di elevate
viene elevato valore sociale ed
economico e si può già fare ecco oggi io
con questo ho terminato il saluto
grafico
[Musica]